I didn't realize that everybody here
dresses up every year they need it
it's Halloween that is really really
good timing wow you guys look amazing
Stanley I thought you hated Halloween
Shh he wears it so we can sleep at his
desk who are you
I'm Carrie Bradshaw from Sex in the City
mm-hmm I like your shoes
thank you will you help walk me to the
fax machine sure I got her I got I can
help you
you look amazing inappropriate thank you
who are you Larry King Gordon Gekko all
over the insurance cover sauce yeah whoa
awesome let's put a smile on that face
Damocles I've been up since old work
real sweet stoom did are you supposed to
be Dave cool you are okay we were
looking for kitten
once again Jim Halpert
a New York happy Halloween my costumes
getting a lot of attention so apparently
no one dresses up for Halloween here I
wish I'd known that before I used grease
paint for my mustache and I can't even
take off my hat because that I'm Hitler
wanna see a magic trick I'm gonna make a
pencil discipline disappear what is that
what are you supposed to be
I'm three-hole punch version of Jim cuz
he can have me either way plain white
Jim are three-hole punch
yeah yeah well look what about me what
are you a monk I'm a Sith Lord big deal
three round pieces of paper taped to his
shirt this cost me $129 yes your
gangster pumpkin on his pallet truck of
doom
don't worry about a thing rest assured
you see me later we are doing a haunted
house this Halloween which is actually
kind of spooky because as legend has it
on this very site there used to be a
productive paper company I am going to
scare these kids so bad this is the
spookiest warehouse in the world kids
you don't believe me just take a look
whoa
scary huh this is a surgery with an
octopus and a burn victim black widow
Leeloo from The Fifth Element nobody
told me what people were all right so
label yourselves or take what you get
I bought two jelly or beer it's really
not the trend of vampires right now here
is an old man and a golf dude
and then the old chrome from drag me to
hell I'm a hobo I asked for a list and a
clown jigsaw idiot you know scary is a
book face over there yes I am the
popular social networking site known as
book face okay here's you all been so
good and unbelievably patient so I think
you are gonna get some candy
[Applause]
kids just remember suicide is never the
answer all right
why is Christmas the only holiday that
can have a message it is the easy way
out you are not alone what the hell is
wrong with you
who wants candy kind of statement are
you making with that costume Kevin the
statement that I am making Oscar is I
kind of look like Michael Moore Thunder
Mifflin this is airing happy Halloween
how can I hurt you today a lot of people
really get into Halloween this year has
got a lot of fun stuff planned including
a costume contest and bobbing for apples
and a Ouija board
oh boo explosion macGruber it's a great
stick right it's really good classic I
feel like you might win the whole thing
with that Thanks
everyone realizes this coupon book is
not actually worth $15,000 right you'd
have to spend $200,000 on crap you don't
even need to get $15,000 worth of
benefits I'm not the only one who sees
this right approved chef from South Park
it's genius
just some chef I've decided to
pre-screen all the Halloween costumes
this year I have three simple rules
don't be offensive
don't be cliche and don't take the first
two rules too seriously the gorilla from
Rise of the Planet of the Apes huh the
one who sacrifices his life whoa
Oh spoiler alert it's been out for ages
man costume vetoed yeah somebody's
already called that who kevin has a
gorilla suit you can borrow this is
ridiculous why can't there just be two
Kate Middleton's
guys I know I mean I wish there could be
two it's like I can't choose they're
both amazing it's just look I stayed up
all night and I watched that GD wedding
and then I came to work and I made
everyone else watch it all day
wasn't even here because I was there
your sister's funeral what I said was my
sister's funeral is this weekend didn't
say I'd be there why is it such a shock
that I followed a royal story warms my
heart thinking about them two kids doing
it I present to you the rational
consumer as it were I don't like your
tone look they were sold out of all the
other costumes okay I think we all live
in the real world here let's not pretend
to be unaware of what sells in this
office this year I decided to really get
into the spirit of Halloween it may have
been the costliest decision I've ever
made
my greased-up head went into the pumpkin
no problem but watch I can't get it out
try again
I mean I could try destroying the
pumpkin no no no what as Jim and I
discovered no any blow to the pumpkin
itself could prove fatal to me at first
I drove myself crazy thinking about the
things I should have done differently I
never should have played that joke on
Aaron he never should have a load out
this damn pumpkin in the first place but
then I realized I was being silly
I mean the pumpkin should rot off of my
head in a month or two right okay
everyone I've tallied the votes and the
winner of the costume celebration
spectacular and the
scranton/wilkes-barre coupon book
skur Martinez if I have to vote for
someone I don't want it to be someone
who can beat me shake things up I'm a
Nader guy best edward james olmos
costume I've ever seen freaky good
you